my name is Ando with SEIU occupy LA is
the largest encampment left do you think
you're learning for what happened the
other cities no we're trying to be
preventative like I said obviously if
they want to come down on us hard they
will
how do you feel about how that went
protests we are one we are Amma we are
eternal forever come back in dissolve
evil [ __ ] Satan Satan you're gonna
dissolve how can you not keep up grey
aliens [ __ ] all you extraterrestrials
may the divine beings alike communicate
with us can try to be with us in our
dreams fine [ __ ] the grey aliens what's
wrong with the grey alien the grey
aliens
their control by the reptilians they're
Chileans are like drunk aliens and
everything kill Illuminati kill
Illuminati's wherever eternal meditation
is a key I'm not saying this to make I
don't see things escalating here I mean
there's of course there's most of the
violence occurred has been due to
individual elements that have
infiltrated their way into a peaceful
movement anybody who's actually out here
for occupy isn't out here to be violent
this morning there were 23 arrests this
afternoon right now we've had a total of
three generally therefore four oh seven
of the
which is unlawful assembly and you
continue to monitor the protest just
like we always do in case somebody
decides to break the login we provide
them the opportunity to go to jail
despite these arrests today occupy Los
Angeles has not turned violent
unlike other movements across the u.s.
the encampment on LA City Hall lawn
remains the largest occupation in the
country and occupiers have no intention
of leaving anytime soon
we have First Amendment rights the right
to freedom of speech and the right to
peacefully assemble I mean the most
exciting part is not knowing what's next
not knowing what's gonna happen not
knowing if this is gonna get read it out
tomorrow we actually have a stamp from
the mayor recorded so that we do not
have great so I can't speak for the
powers that should not be in terms of
how long they will let us be here but
you know what our permit is the First
Amendment and there it is that's why I'm
here